où se situe le canada par exemple si on
prenait la richesse alors il ya toutes
sortes de façons de calculer la richesse
on se fie en fait au classement de la
banque mondiale qui a décidé de choisir
le produit intérieur brut par habitant
est en fait on met toutes ces chiffres
là dans un même panier pour avoir un
dollar internationale comme ça on a une
parité pouvoir d'achat donc ça permet de
vraiment bien comparer d'un pays à
l'autre alors qui est le pays le plus
riche avec le pib en fait c'est le qatar
puissance pétrolière évidemment regardé
146 mille dollars suivi de macao de
singapour un pays qui nous ressemble un
petit peu c'est la norvège qui arrive en
sixième position regarder quand même la
différence on parle de 146 mille à 64
mille dollars
les etats-unis ne sont pas très loin
dernière 8e et oussou et le canada il
est ici regardez 17e avec 44 mille
dollars alors on va dire
l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur mais
parfois ça aide cela étant dit on est
quand même dans le classement des pays
qui ce qui peut se dire vraiment heureux
regardez plutôt le numéro un c'est la
suisse l'islande danemark norvège et le
canada quand même cinquième set un
classement quand même sérieux fait par
l'onu c'est quand même pas mal hein on
se laisse quand même assez bien comme
quoi baisse ce sont des pays qui sont
relativement nordique donc on essaie de
se réchauffer le bonheur bon évidemment
on se souvient du premier ministre le
chrétien qui avait parlé du plus
meilleur pays du monde
est ce que c'est encore le cas qu'est ce
qu'il en est mais en fait ça a beaucoup
changé c'est le fameux indice de
développement humain regardait plutôt où
on en est aujourd'hui c'est encore une
fois la norvège pays favoris dans tous
les classements l'australie la suisse
les pays bas les états unis en cinquième
ou et le canada il se trouve maintenant
en huitième position
alors on sait que monsieur chrétien
avait fustigé un peu monsieur ya
quelques semaines de cela en dix ans
n'est plus le meilleur le plus meilleur
pays au monde en début de huitième et
monsieur rappelant à ce moment-là a
sorti un autre classement qui est
compliquée par un réputation institute
qui est une des runes une classification
assez particulière est ce qu'il faut six
filles et ça c'est une autre question
mais effectivement le canada est premier
devant la norvège suède suisse et
australie
bon parlons des villes parce que aussi
beaucoup de classement de vie
de l' indice du bonheur ou la vie dans
les villes commencent situe alors mais
en fait on n'est quand même pas si mal
si on regarde les v nous la qualité de
vie est la meilleure en fait c'est
melbourne en australie en autriche et
viennent ensuite on a un beau chapelet
ici deux villes canadiennes vancouver
toronto calgary égalité avec adélaïde en
australie
montréal votre ville et en 17e position
et évidemment damas c'est évidemment
très très loin c'est la dernière donc
140 pour terminer quand même un petit
indicatif assez intéressant où est ce
qu'on vit le plus longtemps
et bien en fait c'est un monaco il faut
être riche là bas le japon est pas loin
84 ans quand même ensuite la principauté
d'andorre singapour hong kong et le
canada se trouve ou et bien se trouve
ici en 12e position quand même 80 deux
ans et demi c'est pas si mal est
l'endroit le pire sur la terre on ne vit
pas très vieux c'est la sierra leone
regarder sans 93e place avec 47 ans et
demi on peut quand même se consoler
voilà pays d'afrique évidemment c'est
très difficile on va conflit merci
frédéric alors